hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for my
game of thrones Q&A today lots of
questions about where things are going
based on changes they made so I tried to
include as many non spoilery things as
possible I also saw a lot of Brienne
jokes so just as we intuit careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet I think my favorite joke was
when Sansa got mad at breanne for being
at Joffrey's wedding in her defense it's
not her fault she wasn't there in the
books so here we go first question
Kaiser red s why doesn't Brienne mention
the fact that aria lives to Sansa
because everyone else thinks she's dead
I think that she probably just forgot it
and the writers probably excluded that
because they felt it would create more
problems in the narrative the episode
this is one of those logic issues
normally you would expect that brain
would say hey your sisters still alive
and maybe that wouldn't I Sansa to go
with her and then they could go track
down aria but that would pull the story
in a vastly different direction than the
writers want to go so the convenient
thing to do is just exclude it just make
brie and forget to mention it as much as
it seems weird you have to remember that
brianna is a normal person and think
about all the times you talk to your
friends and you just you forget to
mention things so if you really want to
nitpick you could chalk it up to that
but really I think the writers just
excluded it because they didn't want to
pull the story in a different direction
next question Nick asks could you do a
video explaining the Martell family like
why they're called princes I assume you
mean when the rest of the people in
Westeros are called Lords and like
there's only one King so why are there
Martel's called princes the Martel's are
part of the Seven Kingdoms so
technically like in the hierarchy they
are Lords but it's a runner tradition to
call yourself a prince so they give
themselves the Prince Princess titles
for cultural reasons it doesn't give
them extra power it's just they're
upholding traditions other ancestors I
may have explained in a previous video
but princess Nymeria was a runner
princess when the Valerians invaded
their homeland in the east she led them
across the land bridge and created what
is now modern day Dorne so when people
talk about ruiner traditions they're
talking about those people next question
Chris asks what do you think the
significance of drogon sniffing Danny's
hand and flying away is well I think
that they included that just to show
that the dragons haven't lost their bond
with Daenerys drogon is still bonded to
her even though he's flying free it's a
contrast to wriggle on Viserion who are
chained up beneath the pyramid and going
crazy Dan and Dave just don't want you
to be confused and think that the
Dragons have completely turned on her
they haven't like the dragons that have
chained up or just really pissed donairs
also made it seem like drogon had left
for good so it was just a reminder that
drogon is not gone for good it's like
he's just checking in with mom before he
goes off and has some more fun next
question kevin s i think jon snow will
have to learn that he is actually a
start before he'll accept Stannis's
offer to legitimize him well technically
I think he does know that he is a stark
he thinks that Ned is his father so that
would make him a star it's just that he
thinks his mother is some other commoner
I talk all the time about how I think
that his real mother is Lyanna stark and
his real father is Rhaegar Targaryen
that would give him very pure royal
blood but in the line of succession he'd
still be viewed as something of a
bastard you could also view bastards as
children born out of the line of
succession so like during the Targaryen
Civil War during the dance of the
Dragons the the spin-off story that
george RR martin wrote there were
Targaryen xin the direct line of
succession that we're having children
out of wedlock with other Targaryen so
technically they're bastards even though
they have pure Targaryen royal blood it
gets a little messy so I think we'll
have to wait to see if the show deals
with it and how they explain it what I'm
hoping is is that george r martin will
will spell this out in greater detail in
winds of winter so we'll actually have
some cannon to go on right now it's all
conjecture next question elements to do
is ask since all of the faceless men are
no one do you think that jack and a gar
is more or less a pseudonym that they
give to the many-faced God like a mantle
that all faceless men wear so you're
asking like is that a name that they
just pass around no I think that that's
just a name that he chose for the
mission he was on when he met aria it's
a little fuzzier in the book so I'm
gonna focus more on the show's
interpretation the reason I think that
they're still calling him jack and Hegar
on the show is just for simplicity sake
just just so that viewers don't get
confused what Jack and is trying to tell
aria is is that he has no true identity
he takes on any identity that he needs
based on the missions that he goes on
just to take it a step further though
identity is a big deal this season like
who are you do you have royal blood even
though you think you're a bastard or in
the case of aria can you leave your
identity behind as characters of all
through the next couple of
seasons you just you'll see their
identities change although I you know I
think that you know by the end everyone
will return to baseline but what I
really like to see in the finale is is
like you know they go through this big
journey but then they all come back
together and it's like a bunch of Starks
versus a bunch of white walkers next
question Jake asks can people from the
UK use HBO now so you do actually have a
version of HBO now through your cable
provider I think the people that
broadcast HBO internationally like they
might call it something different but
there are simulcasts happening across
the world if you do live outside the
United States and you're not sure
whether or not you have access to
simulcast through your cable provider
just check on their website that they'll
probably stay there HBO now is just the
name of the simulcast service that Apple
prayed a premium to get HBO signed other
streaming deals with other providers but
they had to call it something different
the funny twist is is that Apple only
paid for the HBO now name they didn't
pay for exclusive rights to simulcast so
yes there are simulcast outside the
United States legitimate not pirate
streams next question make asks what
kind of a role do you think that Kevin
Lannister will play well so he said he
was heading back to cashling rock so I
don't think that we're gonna see him for
a while I think Cersei will take care of
herself like she'll be her own worst
enemy for the next couple of episodes I
do think the Kevin will come back but if
you have read the books I think they'll
just they'll cut out a lot of his book
story but thematically a lot of it will
still be there next question Matt asks
is Duran Martell ever going to get up
and start seeking revenge to avenge his
brother yes he has like a very specific
revenge plot he's just much more
calculating than the stand snakes ilaria
sanded is just way more trigger-happy
Duran Martel is like the real master
planner that's why they call it the
Dornish master plan I don't know how
many episodes he's in this season but I
don't think that will start to see that
master plan play out until he's on
screen again and even if it does happen
they could push it into season six so we
might not learn more about it to like
way way later this season next ? s asks
do you think that Tristan Martell will
end up playing Quentin's role so for
those that haven't read the books there
they're like other Martel's that they
just cut out of the show no I don't
think that Tristan is going to do any
Quentin stuff I think they just they
completely cut that stuff out because
Georgia
and has so many other characters in the
books that the show has just had to
exclude you have people going all over
the world doing things that just we
won't ever see on the show that's why
sometimes when I try to explain stuff
i'll say you know if you haven't read
the books don't worry about XYZ plot
because it doesn't matter whenever they
do release winds of winter i'll do some
more like specific book related videos
most of the time I try to make these
videos more about the show but sometimes
it helps to reference the books if it
adds some more context to what's going
on next question evil grin masks when
are they going to show bran stark his
story just started to get interesting
last season so the way Dan and Dave
explained it his story is just like in a
place it's like so far ahead of the
other characters they're just not ready
to go forward with him I think his story
gets more tied up with the war with the
White Walkers and we haven't even seen
White Walkers yet this season I think
that'll start to play out when we get up
to hardhome so once we get into that I
think we'll see some White Walkers and
then its season six brand will come back
and he'll be necessary because it's like
oh look at this army White Walkers we're
right near to this giant forest we need
someone who has power over nature to
help us out thank you so much everyone
for so many questions these are always a
ton of fun to do and thank you everyone
for being good with this blows I know
some of you you know watch the leaked
episodes is ok I don't mind people
commenting that stuff as long as they
use like liberal spoiler tag just
because there are a lot of people that
don't want to hear about that stuff big
thank you to everyone contributing
subtitles to thank you so much that's
been such a huge help congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner metal tester
you win a subscription to HBO now it's
basically like an iTunes gift card
because you have to buy HBO now through
the apple store just DME on the back end
of my channel so I get your contact info
just a reminder to the people that won
the books the signed copies of George RR
Martin's books no one has contacted me
about that yet if no one contacts me in
the next couple of weeks I'll just roll
them out for a new giveaway technically
as of right now you still you still have
a chance to win signed copies of George
are Martin's books my schedule the next
couple days is going to be a little bit
weird I'm seeing an early screening
Avengers age of Ultron as part of this
like special marathon so I'll try to
keep you guys updated you can follow me
on Twitter and Facebook for updates on
what's going on with videos and stuff if
you don't know how to find me there
there are links at the bottom of the
description but while you guys wait for
the rest of my videos this week you can
click here for my episode 2 video if you
haven't seen it yet and you can click
here to learn all about the house of
black and white thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you